ALAN PRICE: The John F
Kennedy Presidential Library
and Museum.
And with my colleague
Steven Rothstein
from the Kennedy Foundation.
We and all of our
colleagues welcome you
to the Kennedy Library.
I'd like to
acknowledge and thank
the generous support of our
underwriters of the Kennedy
Library forums.
Lead sponsors, Bank of
America, the Lowell Institute
and Gourmet Catering.
And our media
sponsors, the Boston
Globe, Xfinity, and WBUR.
I'm delighted to welcome
all of you who are watching
tonight's program online.
If I can ask an enormous
favor of you all,
please silence your
mobile devices.
So that they are not
disruptive during the program.
Thank you.
We will be collecting
questions in writing
throughout the
conversation this evening.
Our team will be
passing through the hall
periodically with
cards and pencils.
And they can collect
your questions that way.
Tonight, we are honored to
welcome his excellency, Juan
Manuel Santos.
The President of the Republic
of Colombia from 2010 to 2018.
He was awarded the
2016 Nobel Peace Prize
for what the prize committee
described as quote,
his resolute efforts to bring
the country's more than 50 year
long civil war to an end.
He is currently the Angelopoulos
Global Public Leaders Fellow
at the Harvard Kennedy School.
He has served as Colombia's
first foreign trade minister.
And also served as finance
minister and national defense
minister.
He created the good
government foundation,
Fundición Buen Gobierno.
During his time working
as a columnist and deputy
director of El Tiempo
newspaper Santos
was awarded the King of
Spain prize for journalism.
He was also elected president
of the freedom of expression
commission for the
inter-american press
association.
I'm also delighted to introduce
our moderator for this evening.
Ricardo Hausmann is
director of Harvard's center
for International Development.
And Professor of the practice
of economic development
at the Kennedy
School of Government.
Previously, he served as
the first chief economist
of the inter-american
development bank,
where he created the
research department.
He also served as minister
of planning of Venezuela.
And as a member of the board of
the Central Bank of Venezuela.
He also served as chair of
the IMF World Bank Development
Committee.
His research interests
include issues
of growth,
macroeconomic stability,
international finance,
and the social dimensions
of development.
Please join me in welcoming
our special guest this evening.
[APPLAUSE]
RICARDO HAUSMANN: Good
evening, good evening.
And thank you for coming to this
a conversation with President
Santos.
I first met President
Santos when he was minister
of foreign trade of Colombia.
And I was minister of planning.
He then went on to become
minister of finance
when I was the chief economist
at the inter-american
development bank.
Then he went on to become
minister of defense.
In between, he created a
foundation on good governance.
After being minister
of defense, he
became president of Colombia.
When we first met, there
were many Colombians
migrating towards Venezuela.
Because we had a higher
standard of living,
better living
conditions, and so on.
These days, Venezuelans
are massively
going towards Colombia.
Now, obviously, that is
in part due to some things
that we did wrong in Venezuela.
But the fact that they're
going to Colombia,
is an indication that you did
something right in Colombia.
So with that perspective of
the last say, 27 years or so,
what went right in Colombia?
JUAN MANUEL SANTOS: Well, first
of all, thank you very much.
I'm very honored to be here.
It's a marvelous place.
Inspiring place.
Inspired by a great
President, John Kennedy.
And thank you, Ricardo,
for being my companion
in this conversation.
Colombia, in the last years,
has had a very positive
transformation.
Well, we've been doing sort of
a set of reforms since we met.
When I was minister
of trade, that's
when Venezuela and Colombia
opened their economies.
We were very close economies.
But then-- I'll go back to
2010 when I became president--
we started the peace process.
We can talk about that later on.
But at the same time, we wanted
to make a series of reforms.
I had the idea of
something similar to what
President Kennedy and then
President Johnson did.
In terms of the
social investment,
the Civil Rights Act.
And we started to have Congress
pass reforms, approve reforms,
which were very important.
For example, in the
last eight years
we made access to our health
system a fundamental right.
And we now have
universal coverage.
We made education free for
every boy and girl in Colombia,
from kindergarten
to the 11th grade.
And we increased, substantially,
the access to higher education.
And for the first time, we put
education on top of our budget.
Usually, for the last 100
years, defense and security
were the number one.
Well, we changed that.
We put education as number one.
We made a very ambitious
program for modernizing
our infrastructure.
And we have, right now,
in place a real revolution
in terms of modernizing
our highways, our ports.
Last time we went to
Bogota, you arrived
to the airport, which is
the most modern airport
in the whole of Latin America.
Number one in cargo.
Number three in passengers
after Mexico and Sao Paolo.
And we put in
place some programs
that allowed us to
improve substantially,
our social indicators.
For example, our
fight against poverty.
And we innovated there.
I had a professor in
Harvard who won the Nobel
Prize in economics.
He comes from
India, Amartya Sen,
who had a very different
idea of measuring progress,
measuring prosperity.
Very similar-- I brought
a part of his speech--
very similar to what Robert
Kennedy had at that time.
I went to the University
of Kansas in 1969.
In March of 1968, Robert Kennedy
went to University of Kansas.
And I have here,
part of his speech.
I want to read it to you,
because it's very inspiring.
He said, even if we act
to erase material poverty,
there is another greater task.
It is to confront poverty
of satisfaction, purpose,
and dignity that
afflicts us all.
Too much for too long, we
seem to have surrendered
personal excellence
and community
values in the mere accumulation
of material things.
Our gross national product now
is over $800 billion a year.
But that gross
national product--
if we judge the United
States of America by that--
that gross national product
counts air pollution
and cigarette advertising.
And ambulances to clear
our highways of carnage.
It counts special
locks for our doors.
And the jails for the
people who break them.
It counts the destruction
of the Redwood.
And the loss of our natural
wonder in chaotic sprawl.
It counts napalm.
And counts nuclear
warheads in armored cars
for the police to fight
the riots in our cities.
It counts Whitman's
rifle and Speck's knife.
And the television programs
which glorify violence in order
to sell toys to our children.
Yet, the gross national
product does not
allow for the health
of our children,
the quality of their education
or the joy of their play.
It does not include the
beauty of our poetry.
Or the strength
of our marriages.
The intelligence of our
public debate or the integrity
of our public officials.
It measures neither our
whit nor our courage.
Neither our wisdom
nor our learning.
Neither our compassion nor
our devotion to our country.
It measures everything
in short, except that
which makes life worthwhile.
And it can tell us everything
about America except why we are
proud that we are Americans.
That was very similar of what
Professor Sen was teaching.
And so I called him.
And I said,
professor Sen, I want
to apply your theory
in my country.
And he said, OK, come to Oxford.
I took the presidential
plane and flew to Oxford.
And he set up a
group of his advisors
and his people who
worked with him.
Went back to Columbia,
and we established
something called a
multidimensional poverty index.
And we approved
laws in Congress.
And made reforms.
And created the institutions.
And started fighting
poverty, measuring
these type of basic
necessities that people
needed to be satisfied.
And that allowed us to
invest our social expenditure
with a much higher
return socially.
And that's why Colombia,
in relative terms,
had brought down poverty.
And extreme poverty.
And inequality,
which is a problem
for all of Latin America,
more than other countries
in our region.
So in all of this, we have
tried to do with what we call,
fiscal responsibility.
You know better
than me and anybody
because your
economics professor,
how to maintain the
confidence in your economy.
And maintain the
confidence of investors.
In order to be
able to grow, it's
one of the necessary conditions.
So, to summarize, Colombia
has had a responsible
macroeconomic policy.
And at the same time, a very
aggressive social policy.
That has allowed us to perform
much better than Venezuela.
I will tell you an anecdote,
which comes to the point
that you were asking.
I was a very harsh
critic of Chávez.
And when I got elected, he
even told my predecessor
that if I got elected, there
would be war with Colombia.
Well, when I got
elected, I decided
to try to make peace
with our neighbors.
Because we didn't
have at that time
diplomatic relations with
Venezuela or Ecuador.
We had very bad
relations with Brazil.
No trade relations.
And so I made peace with Chávez.
And I told him, let's do what
President Reagan told Gorbachev
when they met in Geneva.
And when President
Reagan told Gorbachev,
I will never be a communist
and you will never
become a capitalist,
but let's work together
for a superior objective.
Which is, at that
that conversation,
to reduce the nuclear arsenal.
And I said to Chávez., I will
never become a Bolivarian
revolutionary.
And you will never become
a liberal Democrat.
But let's work
together for peace.
Peace in Colombia, which
is also peace in Venezuela.
And peace in the region.
And he said yes.
And he started criticizing my
economic model, my development
model.
And I said, hey, let's not
discuss our economic models
and our development models.
Let history judge us
some years from now.
Well, I think history has made
a very, very important judgment
comparing Venezuela to Colombia.
People are coming to
Colombia not only because
of the terrible situation
that unfortunately, you're
going through, the Venezuelans.
But also because Colombia
is now offering them
what Venezuela offered
us for many, many years.
A better future, freedom.
Democracy with all
its problems, but we
have a democracy that we have to
strive to strengthen every day.
And that's what we're trying
to recover in Venezuela.
Because unfortunately, Maduro
did away with democracy.
And that's why we have
to all keep the pressure,
to see if we can put Venezuela
again, in the democratic path.
Venezuela is a
very rich country.
A great country,
with great people.
And they don't
deserve what they're
going through at this time.
RICARDO HAUSMANN: Thank you.
Let me ask you, if you
were to in your hat,
not just as former president,
but a former minister
of finance and so on.
What were, if you say,
a lesson of history?
Do this topic this
way, like Colombia.
And not this way,
like Venezuela.
What were the mistakes that
were done in Venezuela?
And the correct policies
that were done in Colombia?
JUAN MANUEL SANTOS: Well--
RICARDO HAUSMANN: Name a few.
JUAN MANUEL SANTOS: In Colombia,
we applied what some of us
call, the third way.
And that's what I would say Bill
Clinton did here, in the US.
What Tony Blair did in the UK.
What Fernando Henrique
Cardoso did in Brazil.
Or Ricardo Lagos in Chile.
You summarize the third
way in a phrase that
says, more or less, that you
allow the markets to perform
until they are able to perform.
But you intervene.
The state intervenes
when it's necessary.
To correct whatever
markets are not doing,
or when then the
markets do not work.
And this pragmatic combination
has allowed the countries
that have applied this third way
to have a period of prosperity
that is much more important
than other periods
in their economic history.
In Venezuela, the approach
was completely different.
The state has to do everything.
The state has to
control everything.
And not only in economic
terms, in political terms.
So, freedom-- which is,
for me, a sacred word--
was sacrificed in Venezuela.
And when you sacrifice
freedom, and you
don't allow the private
initiative and innovation
and the good ideas
to flourish, you
will simply destroy
whatever you have.
And this is what has
happened in Venezuela.
Plus, if you allow
corruption to take over,
well, then you
make things worse.
And unfortunately, Venezuela,
they also allowed corruption.
To take over a system that
was doomed from the beginning
because they were
on the wrong track.
RICARDO HAUSMANN: Very
interesting, let's move on,
now.
You've got the Nobel
Prize for peace.
So before we talk about
peace, let's talk about war.
Colombia had a civil war
that was 50 some years long.
What, in your mind, was
the cause of the war?
And maybe not just the
cause of the war, but what
made it so long lasting?
JUAN MANUEL SANTOS:
Well, Colombia
has been a very violent
country since our independence.
We have had more civil
wars than any other country
in Latin America.
This specific war
with the FARC started
in the early '60s,
when two things were
present at same time.
In the early '60s you had all
these revolutionary movements.
The Cuban revolution and
the communist revolutions.
And so you had the guerrilla
movements, not only in
Colombia and also Venezuela.
And in many countries.
But in Colombia, after our
only military dictatorship--
that in order to topple
this dictatorship
that fortunately lasted very,
very short amount of time--
the two main political parties
decided to share power.
And share everything.
And half of the cabinet it was
liberal, half of the cabinet
was conservative.
All the positions the
government, half and half.
And they excluded
everybody else.
So the revolutionary
movements plus the exclusion
of what we called at that
time the National Front,
gave the correct environment
for the FARC to flourish.
And also we neglected
for many, many years,
and we still are neglecting, the
development in the rural areas.
And this was a rural
guerrilla, a peasant guerrilla.
And when the guerrilla
movement started to fade away,
or to win in other countries.
And in Colombia,
unfortunately, something
arrived that has been a
terrible problem for us,
terrible headache, which
is drug trafficking.
So the FARC discovered a golden
head of the drug trafficking
to finance the war.
So that gave them
an extra muscle.
And so they were able
to last 50 years.
And their idea was a
communist revolution.
And their flag was
social justice.
That's the origin.
From there, they
started to evolve.
Unfortunately, they got
into drug trafficking.
And so their ideals
were starting to change.
RICARDO HAUSMANN:
So before we go
on to the continuation
of war and peace,
maybe you could tell us a
little bit your thoughts
about to what extent, in this
World War on drugs, that caused
so much havoc in Colombia.
Any thoughts on was this the
right way to face the drug
issue?
If you have any
comments on, was it
inevitable that it should
have proceeded that way?
Or were there other
ways in which,
if you are now to
act on drug policy,
what would your drug policy be?
JUAN MANUEL SANTOS: Well I
will tell you an anecdote.
I am a very, very keen
reader of biographies.
The latest biography
of Winston Churchill--
it's a bit long it's a
bit over 1,000 pages,
but it's the best one--
has a story that during
prohibition, Winston Churchill
came to the US through
Canada to California.
And he arrived and
he asked for a drink.
And they said, no
Mr. Churchill, drink
is prohibited in this country.
And he said, what a
strange country this is.
You allow the huge profits
of the sale of liquor
to go to the mafias.
In my country, we give
it to the treasury.
RICARDO HAUSMANN: [LAUGHING]
JUAN MANUEL SANTOS: That's
why it's interesting.
RICARDO HAUSMANN: Now, you
have this guerrilla movement.
It's there, it's outside of
the constitutional rules.
I mean, you change the
Constitution in 1991,
I believe.
You know, that system that
justified the creation
of the guerrilla was change.
You became a more open
democracy and so on.
But the guerrillas continued.
So here, you are they appoint
you minister of defense.
What's your strategy, how
do you deal with them?
JUAN MANUEL SANTOS:
Well, I go back.
I was seeing them and they
were showing me around
and how President
Kennedy was a sailor.
And I was in the Navy, also.
And I learned in the
Navy, how to sail.
And the first lesson
that they gave me,
the officer that
was in charge said,
Santos, he gave
a small sailboat,
go and learn how to sail.
And that was very difficult.
I didn't know what to do
and I really got problems.
And he said, I'll
teach you something
which is going to be
very important to you.
Not only to learn how to
sail, but in your life.
In everything that has
to do with your future.
You always need to know
where you want to go.
And in sailing, if you have,
like, a port of destination,
you can use all the winds.
No matter how strong they are
or if they're against you,
you can use them to arrive
to that port of destination.
That was a very good lesson
that many, many years later
in a conversation, I
had with Nelson Mandela.
I was the chairman of the
UNCTAD, United Nations
Conference on Trade
and Development.
And he got elected
chairman after me.
So I went to Johannesburg,
and I gave him the chair.
That morning, I was in
the hotel in Johannesburg
and I turned on the television.
And I saw the most
incredible life program.
There were the victims of the
war with the perpetrators,
live in television,
confronting each other.
Some of them embraced, others
screamed at each other.
And I couldn't understand.
And I had a 15 minute
meeting with Mandela program
that afternoon.
I went and I asked
him, what is it
that I was seeing this
morning on television?
And that 15 minutes became
five hours of conversation
about peace.
And at the end he
said, your country
will never progress if
you don't end the war.
And then I discovered
at that time,
that that was going to be
my port of destination.
That was early '90s.
So, when I became
minister of defense,
I already knew that
we needed peace.
But to have a successful
peace process,
you need to have the right
conditions, the necessary
conditions.
And one of them was
to weaken the FARC.
To convince them that
through violence,
they will never achieve
their objective.
They will never win.
And so you have to be
successful militarily
in order to take them to
the negotiating table.
And so when I arrived, when
I was appointed minister
of defense, I knew that
I had to be successful
if I wanted to take them
to the negotiating table.
So I had to become a
very effective hawk.
And I was elected
president in the year 2010
because I was a war hero.
And when you were
a war hero, you
exercise a very easy
type of leadership.
In times of war,
you give orders.
And you rally the
forces around you.
And you point at the
enemy, your adversaries,
and you say, let's go
together against our enemies.
That is easy.
But then I have
to become a dove.
And that is much more
difficult. That's
why I say it's much more
difficult to make peace
than to make war.
Because to make peace, the type
of leadership is not vertical,
it's horizontal.
Instead of giving orders,
you have to persuade.
You have to convince the victims
of the war, of the conflict,
to forgive.
And then to tell the
mother of two kids,
or a daughter that had
been raped and killed,
to forgive the perpetrators,
that is much more difficult.
And to heal the wounds
of 50 years of war
takes a lot of time.
But I always knew
that being effective
as a minister of defense
was necessary to be
able to sit down and have
a serious negotiation.
So when I was
minister of defense,
I also learned a
very important lesson
about how to wage
an effective war.
When I came into
the ministry, we
had copied military strategies.
And we had a terrible way of
measuring the effectiveness
of our officers.
We copied that from Vietnam.
The body count, how
many bodies do you have?
And that's what the generals
and colonels were measured by.
And that is a very bad way
to measure the effectiveness
of a an officer.
And one general who had retired,
very intelligent historian,
when I was recently appointed
as minister of defense.
He said to me,
Mr. Santos, you're
going to have to wage war.
Lead the war against the FARC.
But don't treat them
as your enemies,
treat them as your adversaries.
Enemies, you destroy.
Your adversaries, you beat.
And you're going to
have to live with them
for the rest of your life.
I know that you want
peace, so treat them
as sons of the same nation.
They are your brothers.
Humanize the war.
And that will give
you much more respect.
And will give the military more
respect from the population.
Our military were blacklisted
in many of the lists
in the human rights in
Geneva And New York.
So we've made a radical change.
And for example, instead of
a body count, I start saying,
I will measure your
performance by the number
of guerrillas that give up.
Give their arms.
That reincorporate
into civil society.
And we did some very audacious
programs, put in place
with very audacious policies.
Like, for example, we identified
the mothers and the fathers
of many of the guerrillas.
And asked them to
write a message
to their sons or daughters.
And we put these
messages in some balls
that floated in the rivers.
That flowed down to where the
guerrillas were concentrated,
in the Amazon jungle.
And this became for them,
a tremendous incentive
to go and see if their
mother or their father
had sent them a message.
And afterwards, when I
negotiated with them,
after the peace
process, they said,
you cannot imagine how it
was much harder for us,
as commanders.
The morale of our people, what
you did with these messages.
And we also put some lights
in the trees in the jungle
during Christmas.
With messages from
the fathers, mothers
or, sisters of the guerrillas.
And we left, and then
the guerrillas came
and they all competed to
see who had the message.
And the effect on the war,
of humanizing the war,
was much higher.
Had a much bigger impact
than bombing the camps
and killing everybody.
So that is a human
way to win a war.
And that allowed me,
afterwards, to sit down
in a much better environment
to negotiate peace.
RICARDO HAUSMANN: So
when did you decide
to move from war to peace?
JUAN MANUEL SANTOS: When
I got elected president.
Because I had identified the
conditions that were necessary.
I used a lot of the lessons
that I learned here, at Harvard.
Negotiation lessons, the
first lessons I took,
was from a professor
called Roger Fisher.
One of his pupils,
William Murray,
I brought in as a special
advisor for the negotiations
since the very beginning.
And I also used the lessons of
a marvelous professor, whose
100th anniversary was
just recently celebrated,
Richard Newstead.
Vise President Gore was
there in the celebration
of his 100th anniversary.
And I studied all
the peace processes
that have been negotiated.
What was applicable to our
process, and what was not.
What lessons could we learn?
And so, in that
process, I discovered
a series of conditions
that were necessary.
And one of them was
that in today's world,
asymmetrical wars need
the support of the region.
And if possible, of the
international community.
We were going to negotiate peace
under the umbrella of the Rome
statute, which is an
international treaty that
was negotiated to
facilitate negotiations.
And those conditions
were not present
until I became president.
When I made peace, for
example, with Chávez.
Or with Korea, in order
to be able to have
the necessary conditions to
have a successful peace process.
So I switched from hawk to
dove when I became president.
RICARDO HAUSMANN: And so
tell us a little bit more.
So you decided to
go to a negotiation.
What was your
initial strategy, how
did you conceive of the
negotiating process?
JUAN MANUEL SANTOS:
In this process,
of learning from
other processes.
And all my predecessors had
tried to make peace since 1882.
All the presidents of Colombia
had tried and had failed.
So I started to study why had
they failed, what was lacking.
The first thing that I learned,
not only from our own failures,
but from other peace
processes, that you
need a very short
and concrete agenda.
I learned that the less
public your negotiations,
especially at the
beginning, the better.
So we negotiated secretly
for two years, the agenda.
And until we had the agenda,
which is of almost 50%
of negotiations, defined,
then we went public.
We went to Oslo and
made the agenda public.
I learned that the military
were very important to be
part of the process.
All my predecessors thought
that the military would
be spoilers of the process.
But I also learned that there's
a very famous phrase of General
MacArthur, said, if you think
that the military like war,
you don't understand
the military.
The soldiers are the ones
who risked their lives.
They are the most
interested in having peace.
And I know because I
was in the military.
And so I talk their language.
So I brought them in.
Two of my chief negotiators were
the two most popular generals
that Colombia had,
police and army.
And so all these conditions
could not be sort of created
until I was president.
That's why the switch was
made when I became president.
Two years of secret
negotiations and then we
start the public negotiations.
Another very difficult
decision that I took
was, because during the
Ministry of Defense,
we had been able to
get the upper hand
in the military balance of
power with the guerrillas.
Because the
guerrillas had always
taken advantage of
the negotiations
to increase their military
and their political power.
I studied the peace processes
in Israel and Palestine.
And I remembered a strategy
that Prime Minister
Rabin, from Israel, had applied
when he sat down with Arafat.
And he said, I will
negotiate with terrorism,
which was Arafat, as if
there is no terrorism.
But I will continue
to fight terrorism as
if there is no peace process.
So I told the FARC, I'm going
to apply the same doctrine.
We will sit down and negotiate,
but we continue the war.
They wanted a
ceasefire, but I did not
want a ceasefire until I knew
that we could get an agreement.
It's very risky.
It brought me a lot of
problems because people
don't understand.
Why are you talking
to these people
while they committed
all these atrocities?
But in the long run, it's
the most effective way
to get a result.
RICARDO HAUSMANN: What
was your initial thoughts
of what you were going to find
in the FARC in the negotiation?
And what did you
learn about the FARC
through the negotiation process?
JUAN MANUEL SANTOS:
They, in a way,
were getting older,
the grinders.
And another condition
that was necessary
was to convince the
commanders that it's
in their own personal
advantage to negotiate, and not
to continue the war.
When I became minister of
defense, 45 years of war,
and not one single
member of what they call,
the secretariat, like,
the board of directors,
had been captured or killed.
Not one single one, in 45 years.
They had penetrated all
our intelligence agencies.
So I went to a
friend of mine, which
was the prime minister of
Great Britain at that time.
And I told him, please help me.
And he said, what do you need?
I said, I need you
to help me in what
you are the best in the
world, intelligence.
So he got the phone
and dialed the phone
number of a marvelous man
called Sir John Scarlett.
He was the head of MI6,
British intelligence.
He said, I have a friend of
mine, I want you to help him.
I went in his building, it's
a building with no address.
And I had a crash course in
intelligence for two days.
Incredible crash
course that said,
you need to change
your intelligence.
You need to change the way
the intelligence operates.
Your intelligence is
modeled by the Americans.
The Americans have
their agencies compete.
FBI against the CIA
against the DEA.
They all compete.
That won't work in Colombia.
That doesn't work in Colombia
because your intelligence is
made by the different forces.
And they are military
or police, and they
don't have the flexibility.
You have to have a
system like we have,
concentrated under the
Office of the Prime Minister.
This case, on the
office of the president.
This change made
our intelligence
much more effective.
And we started the
taking down what we call,
the high value targets.
And I had to make very
difficult decisions.
For example, one day I was
having dinner with I remember,
the board of directors of
Conservation International
Environmental, NGO.
And the commander of the
Army called me and said,
we have located the number one
person in FARC, the commander.
We've been going after him
for 40 years or 30 years.
And I had to take a decision.
I had already started
the peace process.
But the rules of the
game were Rabin doctrine.
So I had to take the
decision right there.
Do I authorize an
operation against him?
This could simply erase
the peace process forever.
Or a do I withhold, and tell
the military now, you know,
you can't go after him?
Which could mean
that the military
would be very frustrated.
And their support for the peace
process would be weakened.
Well, I took the decision
to authorize the operation.
Because I had told the FARC,
it is legitimate for you
to want to kill me.
In those words, it
is legitimate for me
to go to the war against you.
And they had accepted.
So I said, go after him.
He was killed.
And afterwards.
The FARC told me,
it hurt us a lot.
You're an SOB.
But we respect you for that.
And that helped the trust that
was necessary, in their case,
to be built in order to be
able to get an agreement.
I learned that also,
like humanizing the war,
also humanizes your adversaries.
So they're human beings
with son, with the families.
And that allows you to start
speaking a different language,
with a different attitude.
Of course, we were
miles apart in the way
we thought about the
future of the country.
But slowly, I realized that
what they were asking for
was not that important, if
you weighed the concessions.
They wanted to have a
representation in Congress.
They wanted to be
forgiven for their crimes.
And I said, the base would
be forgiven, not the leaders.
The leaders will be judged,
sentenced, and condemned.
There will be no impunity.
Because the Rome statute
will not allow the impunity.
They wanted to have some
reforms in the rural areas, that
were exactly the same that
were needed for the country.
So I said, OK
that, I can accept.
So I discovered
that there was not
huge differences in what
their expectations were,
and what we could give.
And that facilitated
the negotiations a lot.
RICARDO HAUSMANN: Why
did it take so long?
How long did it take?
JUAN MANUEL SANTOS: It took
six years of negotiations.
And this a very good question.
When people ask me, what would
you have done differently?
One of the things I would
have done differently
is, we negotiated five
points in the agenda.
And we decided to
negotiate in a sequence.
We have to agree
on the first point
to go to the second point.
That was a mistake.
We should have negotiated
simultaneously because time,
and that is the lesson that
I learned afterwards, goes
against the government,
not against the guerrillas.
And because everything
that happens
in the negotiation, will
cost the government,
or the person
representing the state,
will cost him politically.
Especially when
you are negotiating
in the middle of the war.
And that cost me a lot
of my political capital
because it went on too long.
But that's a good question.
They knew that,
and they stalled.
And they were slow
in taking decisions.
And there, I would have
done it differently.
RICARDO HAUSMANN: Very good.
In this country there, is a
huge debate on health care.
There's, you know,
in this country,
most health insurance is
provided by employers.
And then when
people switch jobs,
it generates
uncertainty and so on.
It's very expensive.
It's been on the political
agenda for a long time.
Colombia made a major,
major health care reform.
can you tell us--
JUAN MANUEL SANTOS: Very
shortly, what we did was,
we passed a constitutional
amendment saying,
access to the health system
is a fundamental right.
No hospital can deny
access to any Colombian
who goes there sick.
Also, they were a system
that was subsidized,
and a system that
was by contributions.
We decided to put the
passengers of second class
as passengers of first class.
And we chose the treatments that
were included in the system.
I think we overdid it, our
system is too expensive.
And so we have a
system today that
measured, by
international standards,
they have three ways of
measuring the health system.
What percentage of the
population is covered?
In the case of Columbia,
universal coverage.
How many treatments are
included the system?
The case of Columbia, very,
very high amount of treatment.
Very large amount of treatments.
And what percentage of the
family income goes to health?
We have one of the
lowest in the world.
So we are very well
rated, our health system.
Of course, we have
terrible problems
in the quality of the system.
We have to prove
that and we might
have to reduce the
number of treatments.
But Ricardo, I think I
am the journalist here.
You're not a
journalist then, right?
And I think many
people here would
like to hear about Venezuela.
You're from Venezuela, you
are the expert on Venezuela.
Can I ask you some
questions about Venezuela?
RICARDO HAUSMANN: OK.
[INAUDIBLE] Go ahead.
JUAN MANUEL SANTOS: OK.
At this moment, you've
been very much involved
in the future of
Venezuela, the D-day.
Could you give us
a summary of what
you think will be needed
to recover a country that
has been destroyed?
In many respects,
institutionally,
and the productive sector.
What will it take?
RICARDO HAUSMANN: Well let
me take a short seven hour
stretch.
[LAUGHTER]
I would say, first of all,
the catastrophe in Venezuela
is really a orders of magnitude.
Bigger than anything that we've
seen pretty much anywhere.
And certainly, nowhere
in this continent.
The US Great Depression,
GDP fell by 29%.
I mean, that was
a historic event.
People think that they
ignore our depression
because they went through the
great recession of 2008, 2009.
That saw a decline in GDP of 3%.
The Great Depression, was 29%.
Venezuela had two times the
Great Depression by 2018.
Between 2013 and 2014,
it was a collapse
of twice the Great Depression.
And in 2019, the
expectation is that it
will be a 30% decline in GDP.
So, it'll be another
Great Depression.
Sort of three great depressions.
So--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RICARDO HAUSMANN: So--
RICARDO HAUSMANN: I'll
let you speak afterwards.
JUAN MANUEL SANTOS: Do you--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JUAN MANUEL SANTOS:
Continue, continue.
RICARDO HAUSMANN: No,
no, you're journalists.
Anyway, so, the
collapse is enormous.
This collapse has
essentially two causes.
And it's the two things
that we need to fix.
The first one is that
Venezuelans have been
disempowered from any rights.
You were mentioning before,
you have no right to own,
things can be expropriated
from you with no justification.
And mostly, no compensation.
You don't have the
right to import.
You don't have the right
to buy foreign exchange.
You don't have the
right to set prices.
Or you don't even have
the right to decide
who you sell things to.
So you have a society that
has been disempowered.
People have needs.
Some people would
like to make a living
out of supplying those needs.
They don't have the
rights to do that.
And this all happened
when the price of oil
was still above 100.
So the system was undermining
the basic economy.
The second thing that happened
is that in that period,
where the disempowered society,
they say, well, you know,
if production declines,
it's not a problem.
Because we can import.
And imports went up by a
lot because the price of oil
was high.
But in addition, they
borrowed enormously.
And they were spending
as if the price of oil
was at 200, when it was at 100.
So at some point in time,
capital markets said,
we don't lend to
this country anymore.
So they couldn't
borrow that amount.
And that's what triggered
the initial recession.
And then the price
of oil collapsed.
So now, there's a shortage
of foreign exchange.
So there's no raw materials,
no intermediate inputs,
no spare parts.
So people cannot produce.
They cannot plant.
So there's no seeds, no
fertilizers, no agrochemicals.
There are no spare parts, or
there's no transportation.
There are no buses.
There are no trucks.
There's no cars.
There's no motorcycles.
Because--
JUAN MANUEL SANTOS: Let me
ask you a specific question.
Pompeo, the Secretary of
State, was in Cucutan, Colombia
just two days ago.
RICARDO HAUSMANN: Yes.
JUAN MANUEL SANTOS: And he said
the recovery of Venezuela will
cost about $6-$10 billion.
You think with $10 billion
you can reconstruct Venezuela?
RICARDO HAUSMANN: I think
he was off by a 0 or so.
[LAUGHTER]
But if he were right,
if he could do that,
he would deserve the
Nobel Prize in economics.
Because he will have
discovered a way
to solve the
problems of the world
for a tenth of their cost.
But it will be
very, very expensive
to recover the country.
But I sense that there
is a lot of willingness
to help Venezuela recover.
But I--
JUAN MANUEL SANTOS:
To what extent?
And forgive me for
asking this question,
but you're in Venezuela and
you've been very involved.
The political use of
the Venezuelan drama
has been, in a way, a bad
thing for finding a solution.
What we saw, for example,
with the humanitarian aid.
And both president
of the United States,
the president of Colombia
using that politically
for their own electorate here.
Do you think that it has
been good or it has been bad?
RICARDO HAUSMANN: Well, I
think that in this country,
there's broad bipartisan
support for the restoration
of democracy in Venezuela.
And, you know, you've
seen statements
on both sides of the aisle.
So I hope this does not
become partisan in the US.
Because this is really an issue
of democracy and human rights
and freedom and the restoration
of the Constitution.
And it's an area where both
Democrats and Republicans share
values.
So I certainly hope
that it remains an issue
with broad bipartisan support.
I mean, you know, it has
the enthusiastic support
of prime minister
Trudeau in Canada.
It has broad support of--
JUAN MANUEL SANTOS:
All around, yes.
RICARDO HAUSMANN: All along.
So I think that that broad
coalition is something
that we need to keep together.
JUAN MANUEL SANTOS: And
the thing that [AUDIO OUT]
RICARDO HAUSMANN:
--enough pressure
on the armed forces for them
to return to the Constitution.
They are allowing
president Maduro
to violate the Constitution.
To assert power.
To govern without the
authorization of the National
Assembly, without any
respect to the Constitution.
They should just go back
to the Constitution.
And you can convince them by
forcing them to repress you.
By putting your people
in danger every day.
To go to the streets to protest.
By appealing to their humanity.
By negotiating their
future role in society.
But, you know, what you
said about the FARC,
is that the reason
why they negotiated
is because they
were under threat.
And we don't have
that instrument.
We cannot threaten them.
They are armed,
we are not armed.
So it makes the negotiation
or process difficult.
And you're also unable
to promise them much.
Because they have
nothing to give.
And you have no
credibility in being
able to deliver on
any promises you make.
So that's why it's hard, without
international involvement,
to change the situation.
Well now let me get back
to my role as moderator.
Well, let's start
with an easy one.
My name is Juan David
Gutierres, and I am originally
from Armenia, Colombia.
This is the first
time I verbalize
that I am proud of a Colombian
president because of you.
Thank you for
bringing Colombia back
to a positive conversation.
My question relates to the
impact of the peace process.
Historically oppressed and
marginalized communities
in Colombia.
In essence, I'm talking about
Afro Colombian and indigenous
groups, who have certainly
been the most affected
by the conflict.
How to turn these dominant
narratives of hate?
JUAN MANUEL SANTOS:
Very good question.
The peace has two faces,
two sort of trenches.
First, is what they call
peace making, which is the one
that we already delivered.
We've made peace.
We signed the agreement.
The FARC gave up their arms.
The arms went to the [INAUDIBLE]
nations that were destroyed.
The FARC are now
a political party.
And their members are being
re incorporated into society.
The other part is
peace building.
Which is even more
difficult than peacemaking.
I will tell you an anecdote.
One of my big allies in the
peace process was the pope.
And I used to go visit him.
And I used to tell
him, your holiness,
why don't you go to
Columbia and give me a push?
I need it.
And he smiled I said,
I will go to Columbia
when you will most need me.
And he went to
Columbia's historic visit
after the peace process
had already been signed.
After the arms had
been destroyed.
And he went in a visit
that he, himself,
baptized as, I am going
to Columbia to give
a push to the Colombians.
To take the first step towards--
and these are the magic
words-- towards reconciliation.
Reconciliation with the victims.
Reconciliation among
Colombians that
have been hating each
other for so many years.
Reconciliation with all those
vulnerable sectors of society
that, because of the
war, had been neglected.
And even reconciliation
with the environment.
Because the war has
also terrible effects
in our biodiversity.
And Colombia is one of
the most when the richest
countries in the world, in
terms of the environment
and biodiversity.
So what is happening, and some
reforms have been approved,
is to give these vulnerable
sectors of society
much more space.
And guarantee their rights.
For example, the
indigenous people,
the indigenous communities.
We have been giving them
more autonomy in their health
systems, in their
education systems.
And in their special
justice that they apply.
And this is a process
that is going on.
And now that we have peace,
this should accelerate.
So it's a process
that it started.
And thanks to the
peace process, this
is something that
is now possible.
RICARDO HAUSMANN: Very good.
And I have a question
here from Juan Miguel.
He asks, essentially, why
was Colombia so divided
about the peace agreement?
JUAN MANUEL SANTOS:
That is a good question.
And peace processes
always have enemies.
I remember President
Clinton telling me
that he mentioned this anecdote
in the funeral of McGuinness,
one of the leaders of the
Northern Ireland peace process,
that in the middle of the
peace process in South Africa,
Mandela called Clinton.
And he said, Mr. President,
they are really destroying me.
The criticism is very harsh.
And he said, well,
this is to be expected.
The apartheid people
don't like you.
He said, no, no, no, it's
my own people, the ones that
are criticizing me.
Peace, you have to define,
what is the difficult decision
is, where do you draw the line
between peace and justice?
And no matter where
you draw it, you
will have people
dissatisfied from both sides.
People who don't
understand the concept
of transitional justice.
This is a different
type of justice
that is applied to
peace processes,
like the Colombians, where
the perpetrators of war crimes
don't go to a normal jail.
They are sanctioned to repair
the rights of the victims.
And this is difficult to
understand by many people.
Also, many people take
advantage politically
of this dissatisfaction
from both sides.
And I tell you,
there's a professor
in California called Jared
Diamond who is very well known.
And he went to Columbia.
And he said, I want
to see the president.
And I said, of course.
And he went and said, Mr.
President, I congratulate you.
And I said, why?
Because everybody hates you.
And I said, what do you mean?
And he said, I've been
talking to both sides.
Both sides are dissatisfied.
That means that the
agreement that they made
is a good agreement.
And so it takes time
for people to appreciate
the benefits of peace.
And to heal the wounds
that so many years of war
have produced.
RICARDO HAUSMANN: Well, it's
been less than a year now.
But is it holding?
JUAN MANUEL SANTOS: Well, yes.
This process is irreversible
Nobody in their right mind
can think that FARC we
go back to the mountain.
They have surrendered
their arms.
They are now reintegrated into
politics and in normal life.
The problem with the
peace process in Colombia,
it's probably the most
comprehensive peace process
ever negotiated.
And I don't say this,
all the experts say,
there are two elements
that are very sui generis.
Very sophisticated,
transitional, justice system.
And it's the first time
that the peace process
agrees on development plans
for all the regions that
were affected by the conflict.
Which has 15 years
to be complied with.
People are very anxious that
the road is going to come,
when the school is
going to be built.
And that it is going
to take some time.
But the process,
itself, is irreversible.
And legally, there is
something which people forget.
Our Constitutional
Court made a ruling
that no president, no
Congress, for the next three
presidential
periods, can approve
a law that will go against the
compliance of the agreement.
RICARDO HAUSMANN: I
have two questions here,
that have an
international flavor.
One comes from
Bilbao, Spain where,
you know the
problems they've had
with [INAUDIBLE]
nationalist terrorism.
Question is this is, it worth
to sacrifice justice for peace?
I would like to hear your
personal point of view.
And so that's the
first question,
coming from justice
versus peace.
The second one is, you spoke of
defeating FARC and commencing
a peace process with them.
What advice would you give
to the leaders of Israel?
JUAN MANUEL SANTOS:
Well, the instructions
I gave my negotiators was, go
and negotiate as much justice
as you can, that will
allow peace to be made.
And among the negotiators, there
was an American negotiator.
A professor from the
University of Notre Dame.
Name was Douglass Cassel,
expert in human rights.
And his role in the
negotiation was,
I want to comply with
our own constitution
and with international law.
So everything that
we negotiated,
from the justice
point of view, is
a sacrifice for
the people that are
accustomed to normal justice.
But it's within the range
of the acceptable justice
in today's world.
The International Criminal
Court was the product
of the Rome statute.
And the International
Criminal Court
says what we negotiated
is sufficient to guarantee
that there will be no impunity.
Especially for the
most responsible
of war crimes and
crimes against humanity.
What advice would I give
the leaders of Israel?
Well, first, to stop advancing
in those things that are making
this two state solution viable.
If you continue advancing
with the settlements.
If you continue
taking land, like what
is happening with
the Golan Heights,
make any peace agreement
much more difficult.
I think, like in
any peace agreement,
you need to sit down.
And if there is the will, it
should not be that difficult.
Because other
attempts have almost
defined the two state solution.
If there is the will, I think
that it will be possible.
RICARDO HAUSMANN: Here is a
topic we haven't discussed yet,
tonight.
It says, corruption has
plagued the governments
of all developing countries.
What are your ideas on how to
combat it, how to control it,
how to deal with it?
JUAN MANUEL SANTOS:
I think the best
antidote that any society
can have against corruption
is education.
A society that--
[APPLAUSE]
A society that is
well educated would
be much more resistant to
leaders that are corrupt,
and corruption, in general.
You can also increase
the penalties,
like we have done in
Colombia and many countries.
But it's the values, the
principles, education,
that, in the long
run, will be the best
deterrent for corruption.
I chaired with the prime
minister of Great Britain,
with Desmond Cameron.
The first anti-corruption
World Summit in London.
And from there, the idea of
creating an international court
against corruption.
Because more and more the
corruption is multinational.
It's an idea that is starting
to be discussed in the United
Nations.
And in certain areas.
That could be a complement to
the anti-corruption polices
that each country
should Put in place.
RICARDO HAUSMANN:
I mean, there's
an international dimension
in at least to two cases.
There's the Foreign Corrupt
Practices Act, which makes it
a crime say, in the US, for
a company to bribe abroad.
And there are several cases of
Corrupt Practices in Venezuela,
that are now in American jails.
And there was this whole
international impact
of the Brazilian
Lava Jato scandal
where information was revealed.
Is there now, the typical
thing that countries have done
is to make government
procurement more complicated.
And--
JUAN MANUEL SANTOS: Which
sometimes feeds corruption.
RICARDO HAUSMANN: Do
you think technology
might give us a hand?
Or, I mean,
financial information
might give us a hand?
JUAN MANUEL SANTOS: The best--
I mean, I come from
the journalistic world.
The things that the corrupt
people fear the most
is the lack of public opinion.
And so the more laws that
oblige the government
to be transparent.
To make the information public.
To have the people,
the citizens,
being able to see exactly how
they're spending their money,
and where it goes.
And how the contracts are made.
That helps tremendously.
The role of the
press, when there
is a good press or
an inquisitive press,
governments don't like it.
But it's necessary.
And so there's
different factors that
can contribute to
fight corruption
with more effectiveness.
RICARDO HAUSMANN:
What are the top three
most pressing economic
challenges facing
Colombia today?
JUAN MANUEL SANTOS:
I would say we need
to diversify more the economy.
We still are too much
dependent on raw materials,
basic commodities.
We need to increase
our productivity.
All of Latin America has a
problem with productivity.
If you compare the productivity
in the Asian countries
compared to Latin America,
the growth component
of productivity in Asia
is much, much higher
than in our countries.
So there you have a
problem, but it's also
an opportunity to grow faster.
And I would, again, concentrate
more and more in education.
Because education also helps.
If you give everybody a good
and level starting point,
you also create more equality.
And more equality
is also a factor
that will contribute to
our growth and to progress.
RICARDO HAUSMANN: So says,
as an experienced politician,
negotiator, peacemaker,
and military leader,
what do you recommend
Juan Guaido to do to end
the dictatorship in Venezuela?
JUAN MANUEL SANTOS:
I would recommend
him to use his courage
that he has demonstrated.
And try to build, what they
call the Golden Bridge,
for the regime that
is now in power
to go away as soon as possible.
But with a golden bridge,
if people think that Maduro
will simply say, OK, I'm going.
And he ends up in a jail
like Noriega in Panama,
that will never happen.
So you have to give him a
way out, a dignified way out.
But in order to
do that, you need
to bring in the major
stakeholders of this process,
International stakeholders.
Who are they?
China, Russia, the US,
Cuba, and Latin America.
And if he sits down with Maduro
and says, we will negotiate.
You go out in transition with
the major stakeholders backing
that, you will then have
a peaceful transition.
Because what I fear
most is any transition
which will be violent.
Venezuela, and you know
that better than anybody,
has many, many people armed.
Chávez.
Since the very beginning,
followed the Cuban advice
of arming the defenders
of the revolution.
The institutions
have been destroyed.
The criminal bands
have taken over parts
of Venezuela, especially
the rich parts where there's
gold, where there's coltan.
And in order to be
able to control that,
you have to avoid violence.
Because if violence erupts,
to control that violence
will take a long time.
RICARDO HAUSMANN: I
think we probably have
time for two more questions.
So the first one is from
William [INAUDIBLE] says,
could you explain how
Ser Pilo Paga works?
And--
JUAN MANUEL SANTOS:
Great question,
because it's my
favorite program.
Unfortunately, it--
RICARDO HAUSMANN: Let
me translate it for you.
Being a nerd pays off.
JUAN MANUEL SANTOS: Yes,
Being a good student.
No, we copied that
system from Australia.
There's a similar
system in Australia.
What did we do?
The students that graduated
with the best grades
from the lower strata, the ones
that got the best grades would
have the opportunity go to the
best universities in Colombia.
And the state will pay.
You negotiate it with the
universities and they got in.
The best university in
Colombia is probably Los Andes.
40%, 4-0, of the new
students came because all
wanted to go to Los Andes.
And they competed with
the rich kids from Bogota.
And, of course, they won
their place in Los Andes.
So this is a program that has
tremendous social mobility.
It gives the brightest
the opportunity
to go to the best universities.
It improves tremendously the
quality of the education,
where they go to.
It's a win-win situation
from every point of view.
The present government
decided to do away with it.
Unfortunately, I must
say, because this
is one of the best programs.
It was criticized because the
public university said, well,
why do the students go to the
best private universities?
Well, if you're as
good as the private,
then they will go
to your university.
It's competition.
But the way it worked
was, 40,000 kids
were able to go to the best
universities in Colombia,
from the lower strata.
That not only changed them,
they changed the whole families.
You cannot not imagine the
stories behind each kid or boy
or girl that are now--
I just came three weeks ago I
was the commencement speaker
at the graduation of
the first promotion
of [INAUDIBLE] from Los Andes.
And that was a great revolution.
RICARDO HAUSMANN:
So it's a signal
that there is an activist
policy for social mobility.
JUAN MANUEL SANTOS: Well,
can you imagine the people
from the lower strata
having the access
to go to the best universities?
That immediately
changes their lives.
RICARDO HAUSMANN: This is
a question from Jared Kenny
from Manchester, New Hampshire.
Do you still have your
drive for journalism?
And if so, are there any
stories you'd like to have,
or had the opportunity
to cover as a journalist?
JUAN MANUEL SANTOS: Well,
when I was in government,
I really missed
being a journalist.
Because I was a victim
of my colleagues.
[LAUGHTER]
[INAUDIBLE] some
people in government
don't understand that.
But a watchdog, when everything
is quiet, everything is OK,
he just sleeps.
When he sees something
bad, he barks or bites.
And when you're
in government you
complain, why don't you publish
the good things, the good news?
It's a bias that
journalists have,
but it's a necessary bias.
And I always said that
criticism, and the jurors that
were against the government,
were like a bath of cold water
in the morning that wakes
you up and makes you realize
that you have to work more.
What stories would I cover?
The American election.
It's getting very
interesting, very interesting.
Very good.
RICARDO HAUSMANN:
Would you have a piece
of advice for any of
the candidates running?
JUAN MANUEL SANTOS:
Well, no, it's
very difficult to give
advice for the candidates.
Politics, now, is becoming
very, very different
from traditional politics.
When Kennedy was
elected, you see
in the museum, the debates
between Kennedy and Nixon.
And the importance
of the arguments.
In today's world, the
emotions took over.
And the arguments were
sort of left to one side.
And emotions are very
easily to manipulate.
Fear and hate and discrimination
and nationalism and me first.
These things are very
detrimental to good politics.
Politics, there's transactions.
It's not a black and white.
it's not as zero-sum game.
In politics, you give
something and I gave something,
and we both agree on something.
That's the nature of
politics since the Greeks
invented democracy.
But what you're seeing
now, is the contrary.
So I would say that
any candidate that
can recuperate that
type of politics
based on principles, on
values, and the value of making
transactions.
In the good sense of
making transactions,
that makes a democracy
much more effective.
Polarization, the ones
that we're seeing now
in the US and all around the
world, in my country also,
paralyzes the action
of government.
RICARDO HAUSMANN: Well, ladies
and gentlemen, unfortunately--
[APPLAUSE]
--time's up.
Thank you for coming.
Thank you for your very,
very wide ranging questions.
Thank you, president
Santos, for your thoughts
on so many different issues.
And I'm sure that
you will come back
to this place for
another interesting event
in the near future.
Thank you.
JUAN MANUEL SANTOS:
And thank you, Ricardo.
I asked him right before
coming in, please, have mercy.
He had mercy.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
[NO AUDIO]